besides pmf's and pdfs we can also
describe the distribution of a random
variable as we know using a CDF a CDF is
always well-defined and for the case of
a continuous random variable the CDF can
be found by integrating the PDF and
conversely we can recover the PDF from
the CDF by differentiating there is
something similar that happens for the
case of multiple random variables as
well we can define the joint CDF as the
probability that x and y the pair XY
takes values that are below certain
numbers little X and little Y so we are
talking about the probability of the
blue set in this diagram this
probability can be found by integrating
the joint PDF over the blue set and
since we're using x and y to be some
specific numbers let us use some
different dummy variables to carry out
the integration what is the range of the
integration the first variable which is
s in this integral ranges from minus
infinity up to X and the other variable
which is the one that we're integrating
with respect to in the outer integral
the T variable ranges from minus
infinity to Y now let us see what
happens if we start taking derivatives
of this expression if we take the
derivative of this expression with
respect to Y what is left is the inner
integral and if we take now a derivative
with respect to X of this inner integral
we will be left with just the joint PDF
and it will be the joint PDF evaluated
at the particular limits of the
integration so it's going to be F sub XY
at little X little Y so we have this
particular formula by taking derivative
with respect to X and then with respect
to Y or maybe in the opposite order it
doesn't matter
this particular derivative gives us back
the PDF let us look at an example
suppose that we have a uniform
distribution on the unit square so the
PDF is equal to 1 on this Green Square
and is equal to 0 otherwise so in this
example if we take some x and y so that
the XY pair falls inside the rectangle
the probability of the blue set is going
to be just the probability of that
little rectangle here because everything
outside has zero probability with a
uniform joint PDF which is equal to 1
the probability is just the area of the
set that we are considering and since
this said that we're considering is a
rectangle with sizes x and y the joint
CDF is equal to x times y now if we take
the derivative of this expression with
respect to X and then with respect to Y
then we're left just with a constant
equal to 1 which is as it should be so
that it integrates to 1 so we have seen
that CDF s also apply to the case of
multiple random variables and that we
can recover the joint PDF from the joint
CDF